y es que ya hacía varios días los medios
de comunicación le habían pedido de la
justicia que revelara estos detalles del
allanamiento del fbi porque se trataba
de un tema bastante público 15 cajas que
fueron retiradas se conoció hoy en este
en esta información extra que publica el
departamento de justicia que había
tenido la opción precisamente de para
proteger sus testigos para proteger la
estrategia de investigación contra el ex
presidente le había permitido un juez
federal de la florida que precisamente
redactará que tachar a que pusiera en
negro información confidencial que
pusiera en riesgo la investigación entre
las implicaciones es precisamente eso
que continúe la investigación que
adelanta el fbi y el departamento de
justicia de la razón por la cual después
de que archivos nacionales él estuviera
pidiendo por más de un año al
expresidente donald trump que devolviera
información confidencial porque el
expresidente no devolvió esta
información o lo hizo parcialmente esto
puede llevar incluso a en su momento si
el departamento de justicia lo define
acusaciones de acta de espionaje de
haberse quedado con información que
comprometa la seguridad nacional de
estados unidos pero implicaciones
también tiene de alguna manera positivo
es para donoso antes de cara su campaña
presidencial de reelección en el 2024
porque pues lo que está pasando es que
muchos republicanos se han polarizado
aún más y lo que están haciendo es
empezar a donar ya donar y adorar dinero
y por otro podría estar en este momento
recibiendo cerca de varios millones de
dólares como lo dicen algunas fuentes
acá en eeuu precisamente de donaciones
para apoyar la defensa de cara a lo que
los republicanos dicen es un ataque
contra el ex presidente y cristóbal que
reacciones conocemos hasta el momento
después de la publicación de estos
documentos
pues hace unas horas se le preguntó aquí
desde la casa blanca al express y al
presidente yo bailé que opinaba sobre lo
que había pasado y sobre la información
que se conoció hoy desde el allanamiento
del fbi y él no quiso mencionar mucho no
quiso referirse al tema dijo que esto
era una investigación que adelantaba el
departamento de justicia que se le tenía
que dar pues el tiempo y la libertad a
que el departamento de justicia y el fbi
pues hicieron las recomendaciones
después de su investigación pero dijo
algo que pues generó muchas reacciones
dijo que lo que estaba pasando con él
los republicanos que apoyaban a donald
trump era cierto tipo de semi fascismo y
esto generó todo tipo obviamente de
reacciones en el congreso precisamente
en el congreso también el demócrata que
lidera el comité de inteligencia dice
que es bastante delicado y bastante
importante lo que se conoció en estos
documentos que aunque redactados dicen
la importancia y de alguna manera
justifican porque el fbi se entró a la
mansión de mar al lago casa del
expresidente de donald trump para
adquirir esta información confidencial
entre las cosas que decía era que esta
información estaba completamente
desordenada y les da mucho temor
precisamente a la justicia y al gobierno
estadounidense que donald trump o su
equipo haya compartido esta información
confidencial con agentes extranjeros así
que pues muchas reacciones tanto
demócratas como republicanos pero esto
ha hecho que se paralice aún más el
ambiente político en eeuu